This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. If you've ever wondered what squirrels were good for besides being adorable Wonder no longer these are lettering quills the brushes I was talking about and they generally are squirrel hair That's got Theson from new Bohemia signs a world famous hand painted sign shop in San Francisco. And have pretty long, very thin handles you control them as you're painting an O or an S. Look at any movie made before 1983. And you're seeing hand painted signs everywhere.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。如果你曾经好奇过松鼠除了可爱之外还有什么用处，不用再好奇了。这些是写字用的画笔，也就是我刚才提到的画笔，它们通常是用松鼠毛做的。说话的是来自旧金山世界著名的手绘招牌店“新波希米亚招牌”的斯科特·泰森。这些笔的笔杆很长、很细，你在画字母O或S时可以控制它们。看看1983年以前拍摄的任何电影，你到处都能看到手绘招牌。
You would see a certain type of an A or a certain type of an S being repeated and all this different signage in certain neighborhoods. And that was the first time for me. I realized there was actually a job that was a sign painter. It's not as common a job these days, but sign painting is still thriving. And according to some of the voices you'll meet today, even undergoing a kind of renaissance. But let's start with a cartoonist.
你会看到某种特定的A或S在某些街区的各种招牌上反复出现。那是我第一次意识到，原来还有“招牌画家”这份工作。如今这份工作已经不那么常见了，但招牌绘画依然繁荣。根据你今天将听到的几位受访者的说法，它甚至正在经历一种复兴。但我们还是先从一位漫画家说起吧。
Not just any cartoonist, though. One of America's original underground cartoonists, Justin Green. My comic book, Pinky Brown, meets the Holy Virgin Mary. That's my best known work that I did as a young man. I can't seem to shake a little bastard. I got to see Justin speak last year at this fancy academic comic book conference in Chicago. And he gave me a book of his sign painting comics.
不过，他可不是普通的漫画家。他是美国原创地下漫画家之一，贾斯汀·格林。我的漫画书《平基·布朗遇见圣母玛利亚》，那是我年轻时最出名的作品。我似乎摆脱不了这个小混蛋。去年我在芝加哥参加一个高档的学术漫画会议时见到了贾斯汀，他给了我一本他的招牌绘画漫画。
Reporting right there is our friend Benjamin Walker. The way Justin Green tells it is one night his wife asked him how he was going to pay the bills. And he said, I'm a cartoonist. And she said, I know, but how are we going to pay the bills? But an artist entering the sign painter's world had to tread carefully. Because to tell you the truth among hard-bitten sign painters, the word artist is a majority. Mechanics is the term they use.
正在报道的是我们的朋友本杰明·沃克。贾斯汀·格林讲述的故事是，有一天晚上他妻子问他打算怎么付账单。他说：“我是个漫画家。”她说：“我知道，但我们怎么付账单呢？”但是，一位艺术家进入招牌画家的世界必须小心谨慎。因为说实话，在那些久经沙场的招牌画家眼中，“艺术家”这个词带有贬义。他们用的词是“技工”。
Justin came up with an ingenious way to have it both ways. He threw himself into the world of sign painting, and chronically reading technical manuals written into 20s. Hustling for work, learning on the job, and gathering tips from the elder statesman mechanics, and he documented all of his adventures in a comic strip he called Sign Game. But the best thing about these strips is that Justin actually teaches us how to look at
贾斯汀想出了一个巧妙的方法，让自己两全其美。他投身于招牌绘画的世界，如饥似渴地阅读20年代编写的技术手册。他四处奔波找活干，在工作中学习，并从老一辈技工那里收集技巧。他将所有的冒险经历记录在一本名为《招牌游戏》的连环画中。但这些连环画最棒的地方在于，贾斯汀实际上教会了我们如何观察
old hand painted signs. I literally did that. I mean, I would stand in front of these old sunburned signs like a history detective and I would see how good the craftsman were. If someone was a fledgling or a drunk, you would see lots of brush work around the tricky parts like an old, an old, by an old timer was done in about four strokes, amazingly. Although any neophyte can use 50 strokes to get in the ballpark. But at that point, you can't make a living.
旧的手绘招牌。我真的照做了。我的意思是，我会像历史侦探一样站在这些被太阳晒得褪色的旧招牌前，观察工匠们的手艺有多好。如果某人是个新手或酒鬼，你会看到在复杂的部位有很多修补的笔触；而老手大约四笔就能搞定，非常神奇。虽然任何初学者都能用50笔画个大概，但那样的话，你是没法以此为生的。
So you very quickly learn how to coordinate your eye and hand. It's mind blowing to think about what was done by hand and in comparison to, you know, how things are done now. That's Faith Levine. She just co-directed a movie about sign painters. It also wrote a great book with a guy named Sam Maken. My name is Faith Levine. Faith and Sam interviewed a number of sign painters, including Justin Green. To tell a story about a group of people who used to be in charge of how our cities look.
所以你很快就会学会如何协调你的眼睛和手。想到这些是手工完成的，再对比一下现在人们做事的方式，真是令人震撼。那是费丝·莱文。她刚刚联合执导了一部关于招牌画家的电影，还和一位叫萨姆·梅肯的人合写了一本很棒的书。我叫费丝·莱文。费丝和萨姆采访了许多招牌画家，包括贾斯汀·格林。讲述一群曾经负责我们城市外观的人的故事。
Certain letter forms were ideal for a barber shop and yet not for a restaurant. Sometimes I think the most well-designed signs are the ones that we don't even notice, like a no parking sign or the street signs that tells how to get where we're going. And so, you know, we got a lot of really amazing stories about people, you know, getting jobs, lettering all the street signs for an entire city back in the day. This was a standalone trade and industry that employed, you know, thousands of people
某些字体适合理发店，却不适合餐馆。有时我认为设计得最好的招牌是我们甚至没有注意到的那些，比如禁止停车标志或告诉我们如何到达目的地的路标。所以，你知道，我们收集了很多关于人们的故事，比如过去有人承包了整个城市所有路标的刻字工作。这是一个独立的行业，雇佣了成千上万的人，
that had a direct impact on or hand in, you know, defining our commercial landscape. All of the sign painters Sam and Faith introduce us to are unique. But as a group, there's a consistency to these unique individuals. They're characters for lack of a better word. Or as Justin Green puts it. Anyone in the sign field is a little bit nuts. We got some wild stories.
对定义我们的商业景观有着直接的影响或参与。萨姆和费丝介绍给我们的所有招牌画家都很独特。但作为一个群体，这些独特的人身上有一种一致性。用一个词来形容，他们都是“怪人”。或者正如贾斯汀·格林所说，招牌行业里的每个人都有点疯。我们有一些疯狂的故事。
Many of the sign painters use their painting skills to crisscross the country. Bob Doors says that he could just show up in a town on a Greyhound bus, sleep in a field, and be painting a sign the next day. It seems you can't be a good sign painter unless you're also a good hustler. You got a new business that opens, you walk in,
许多招牌画家利用他们的绘画技能走南闯北。鲍勃·多尔斯说，他可以坐灰狗巴士到一个城镇，睡在田野里，第二天就开始画招牌。看来除非你是个精明的推销员，否则你成不了一个好的招牌画家。你看到一家新店开业，你走进去，
and you say, hey, I'm your guy. I'm going to make people come into your shop because I'm going to paint the sign that people are going to walk by, stop, look at, and come in the door because it looks so good. And that is your hustle as a sign painter. And that's what it was, and that's what it still is. At the heart of the sign painter hustle
然后说：“嘿，我是你要找的人。我会让人们走进你的店，因为我会画出一个让路人停下脚步、驻足观看并走进门的招牌，因为它看起来太棒了。”这就是作为招牌画家的推销之道。过去是这样，现在依然如此。招牌画家推销的核心
is a promise that whatever you have me put pain on, a wall, a sandwich ward, or the side of your truck, it's going to make you and us both look good. You know, I'm gonna make sure that this truck stops traffic. But the thing is, there was never just one guy doing the sign painter hustle. Sign painting was competitive. It was very, very hard to break into the business.
是一个承诺：无论你让我把字画在哪里——墙上、三明治广告牌上，还是你的卡车侧面——它都会让你我看起来都很棒。你知道，我会确保这辆卡车能吸引路人的目光。但问题是，从来不止一个人在做招牌推销。招牌绘画竞争激烈。进入这个行业非常、非常困难。
It's like you couldn't get hired if you didn't have experience, but they didn't want to hire someone with experience because they didn't want them to take all the jobs. You really had to kind of earn your stripes. We're talking about a minimum of two years experience to even call yourself, you know, a sign painter and even that, it could be debated. Because you need to have the necessary knowledge of how to form the letters, lay out the wording,
就像如果你没有经验就找不到工作，但他们又不想雇佣有经验的人，因为他们不想让这些人抢走所有的活。你真的必须靠自己的努力赢得认可。我们说的是至少需要两年的经验才能称自己为招牌画家，即便如此，这还有待商榷。因为你需要具备必要的知识，知道如何构图字母、排版文字，
certain kinds of informational signs that could be crisp and clear and a Roman-Lator form would be completely inappropriate. That knowledge needs to be just like so baked in that you can then apply it hanging on the side of a building in the winter painting fast. It really is an arduous training aesthetically and physically. In his sign game strip Justin Green tries to help us understand why things used to be done a certain way. In one of his comics he explains why sign painters didn't like to use the color yellow. You're required double coating and faded easily. But in every single one of Justin Green's comics you get a sense that he is scrambling to document a world that is fading away.
某些类型的信息招牌需要清晰明了，而罗马字体则完全不合适。这种知识必须烂熟于心，这样你才能在冬天挂在建筑物侧面时快速作画。这在审美和体力上确实是一种艰苦的训练。在《招牌游戏》连环画中，贾斯汀·格林试图帮助我们理解为什么过去的事情要那样做。在其中一期漫画中，他解释了为什么招牌画家不喜欢使用黄色。它需要涂两层，而且容易褪色。但在贾斯汀·格林的每一部漫画中，你都能感觉到他正在争分夺秒地记录一个正在消失的世界。
I felt compelled to do the sign game as a historical piece because I knew the world around me was crumbling overnight. Sign painting is by no means the only industry that was wiped out by digital technology. But still, I can't help but feel extra sorry for these guys because they got their butts kicked by vinyl. Specifically the vinyl platter, which looks kind of like a big computer printer. The vinyl platters are machines that would basically tap out vinyl letters. You would program in, you know, welcome, and then it would punch out the vinyl letters and you'd weed out the vinyl with a razor blade and put the welcome letters onto the surface of your sign. When vinyl first appeared, no one would accept it.
我感到有义务把《招牌游戏》作为历史资料来创作，因为我知道我周围的世界在一夜之间分崩离析。招牌绘画绝不是唯一被数字技术淘汰的行业。但尽管如此，我还是忍不住为这些人感到格外遗憾，因为他们被乙烯基材料打败了。具体来说是乙烯基绘图仪，看起来有点像大型电脑打印机。乙烯基绘图仪是一种基本上可以刻出乙烯基字母的机器。你输入“欢迎”，它就会刻出乙烯基字母，你用剃须刀剔除多余部分，把“欢迎”字样贴到招牌表面。当乙烯基刚出现时，没人愿意接受它。
And yet for all intensive purposes, it was even better than a hand-painted sign because it was perfect. It was of the same color. It would weather better than paint. And for maintenance, because window washers were enemies, it stood up to them. The vinyl plotter was something
然而实际上，它甚至比手绘招牌更好，因为它很完美。颜色统一。它比油漆更能抵御风雨。而且在维护方面，因为擦窗工是招牌的敌人，它能经受住他们的清理。乙烯基绘图仪是
sign painters really liked to hate in theory. And it was considered like selling out, undermining your brothers in the trade. But then slowly the guys who stubbornly clung to their brushes would call the guys who had the machines when they got in the jam. And they'd say, I'm just going to do this once, you know, but could you, you know, you give me these hundred words and then before long everybody bought into it. By the mid 1980s, sign painters were no longer in charge.
招牌画家在理论上非常讨厌的东西。它被认为是出卖行业，破坏同行。但后来，那些固执地坚持用画笔的人，在遇到麻烦时会打电话给那些有机器的人。他们会说：“我只做这一次，但你能帮我刻这100个字吗？”没过多久，每个人都接受了它。到了80年代中期，招牌画家不再是行业的主导者了。
It's a very simple story. Technology lowers the bar to entry. You've got people that are necessarily the most like visual people sometimes going into like a kinkos or a fast signs and saying, these are the words. And those words are printed it out on a thing they could qualify to sign, and that's what goes up. It's like a tower of Bebel. You know, there's thousands of funds. Fonks named after drill friends. But all is not lost for the sign painters. New and old businesses who want to advertise quality
这是一个非常简单的故事。技术降低了准入门槛。你会有一些并非最具视觉审美的人走进像Kinko's或Fast Signs这样的店，说：“这是要写的字。”然后这些字被打印出来贴在招牌上，这就是最终成品。这就像巴别塔。你知道，有成千上万种字体。字体以钻头朋友的名字命名。但招牌画家并没有失去一切。那些想要宣传店内商品和服务质量与工艺的新老企业，
and craftsmanship of the items and services inside the store want to sign that embodies that quality and craftsmanship on the outside of the store. And back in San Francisco at New Bohemia signs, Scott Theson says business is booming. It seems in the past three or four years there's been a resurgence of especially designers really appreciating hand painted signage. You know, the way the letters flow on the brush, you can do slight things to make the lettering look a little bit better. I think just having something that's hand done,
都希望在店外有一个能体现这种质量和工艺的招牌。回到旧金山的“新波希米亚招牌”，斯科特·泰森说生意非常兴隆。过去三四年里，似乎出现了一种复兴，尤其是设计师们非常欣赏手绘招牌。你知道，字母在笔尖流淌的方式，你可以做一些细微的处理让字体看起来更好。我认为只要是手工制作的东西，
hopefully will always be appreciated. You know, it's the pendulum always swings back and forth. And unlike the cutthroat days of the hustle, New Bohemian now teaches sign painting classes that consistently sell out. And we don't view it as creating competition, we're viewing it as more people see that, you know, what a hand painted sign looks like, more likely someone's going to want it. Heather Harterson is one of the young painters who took up the craft a couple of years ago
希望永远都会受到赞赏。你知道，钟摆总是来回摆动的。而且与过去那种残酷的推销日子不同，新波希米亚现在开设的招牌绘画课程总是爆满。我们不认为这是在制造竞争，我们认为更多人看到了手绘招牌的样子，就越有可能有人想要它。希瑟·哈特森是几年前开始学习这门手艺的年轻画家之一，
and is now a journeyman painter at New Bohemian. Damon, who's the owner, always says, it's not perfect, it just looks really good. And that lends to what makes it beautiful, that little wobble is gorgeous. 99% in visible was produced this week by Benjamin Walker. For the intro, I imagine, you know, I'm Roman Mars and I'm talking about the cities and the signs how it used to be or my deep, backlit observations, blah, blah, blah. Sam Greenspan and me Roman Mars.
现在是新波希米亚的一名熟练画家。店主达蒙总是说：“它不完美，但看起来真的很棒。”这正是它美丽的原因，那一点点晃动非常迷人。《99%隐形》本周由本杰明·沃克制作。至于开场白，我想，你知道，我是罗曼·马斯，我在谈论城市和招牌，谈论过去的样子，或者我深刻的、背光式的观察，等等。萨姆·格林斯潘和我，罗曼·马斯。
It's a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. I tweet at Roman Mars, but we have a signed game comic from Justin Green, pictures from New Bohemia and a trailer for the Sign Painters movie all at 99%invisible.org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是旧金山91.7本地公共广播电台KALW和旧金山美国建筑师协会的一个项目。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目。我在Twitter上叫Roman Mars，但我们有贾斯汀·格林的《招牌游戏》漫画、新波希米亚的照片以及《招牌画家》电影的预告片，都在99percentinvisible.org。目前该剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。